pinger are you owe me no Italian now II
don't wanna pass our Tea Party and Who
am I - here Monsieur
sorry me CK Metheny I'm a mummy - okay
so a psychopath you know Montero a
paternal and Oquendo point to maintain a
[ __ ] you mama know me on happiness area
know me I have a penis area can cover -
come on Mariah you are entering a
different [ __ ] dimension you
understand me you used to smoke him with
these okey-doke [ __ ] but uncle
Joey shows up and changes the whole
[ __ ] thing cuz we go deep in the
mornings we're not smoking for flavor
when I smoking with a [ __ ] goatee
we're taking this to the next level
[ __ ] you understand me so it's up to
you
if you're on the 18th
if you're an 18 hang up now I ain't no
Woody Allen look-alike [ __ ]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here on a Thursday morning
feeling chip for the sun's out the birds
are chirpin your sperm is ready to shoot
somebody's [ __ ] and eyeball you got the
American flag on your [ __ ] heart
usulutan [ __ ] what it's
happening you bad [ __ ] checking
in with your making sure you're gonna be
at the Sacramento punchline tonight
myself and Felicia Michaels taking it
back old-school you know Sam we didn't
[ __ ] around without Thursday you gotta
get upgrade most of America's that
gluten-free help get the [ __ ] out of
here this is it right here
This Is It this is my green nutrients
uh-huh [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with uncle Joey here full effect on a
Thursday morning slinging dick and
giving our [ __ ] bad advice
but as usual will set me Eric mad free
to start off the day will write my boss
flannel those fruit smoothie with flax
seeds and to control the [ __ ] whoosh
whoosh and beside that I don't know what
the [ __ ] to tell you I'm ready erupted
and I hope you're ready around go get
you that no time to bleed Jack may be
feeling down I'm tired
hey hurt my back could zoom but class I
don't give a [ __ ] you gotta go out there
take it to the next [ __ ] level
because if not people gonna eat you for
lunch that's that's the state of mind I
told you [ __ ] when I wake up I
smoke there's no [ __ ] nasara there's
no people get little fire blood specks
like I told you I got a [ __ ] thorn
crown on my dick from the pain in my
heart I don't give a [ __ ] what it's a
beautiful day to be alive the attitude
is right you'll fight you the right
place I got my [ __ ] spear here to
clean out the pipe to refill it I don't
know if I told you this I'm already
[ __ ] stoned but I don't really like
them
I've been out here often and bright and
[ __ ] stupid Joseph's out there is
more
we need smoke
during our Bernal crane back has just
that respect that's not his world a
little smoke but you know I had they
don't you milligrams it me and I went
home I was [ __ ] nappy no no one by
[ __ ] 9:30 last night to jujitsu
glasses he had beaten riding yeah it's
[ __ ] tight man I'm gonna [ __ ] man
I got spirits in there speedy balls my
balls but you know what we're all good
was weighted and put together with you
you're with me and they wanna be with us
but they'll never do it just a shitty
week Mickey Mouse
we anyway this Mickey Mouse from [ __ ]
sunset airborne I got I'm still smoking
the exclusively sunset how much [ __ ]
sad is that one of the best weeds around
I'm messing up my goal of sunset arable
come over with my people at perennial my
main man [ __ ] Gino a speed wave you
don't made them but anyway it's Thursday
you gotta be on a point of it and I know
you will be pulling that [ __ ] clown
at that right there brought out on a man
in a casket he's standing up and he
wants his money back
anyway shout out the tibi Julius see
goblins my favorite [ __ ] nephew
whoops my main man great powers have lit
up their Seattle [ __ ] this smoker let
down my people up in Portland I'll come
to see you soon [ __ ] Sacramento this
week we had a man I got [ __ ] up making
moves without service and I know you're
making moves do this together
what what it came from dead
we show up and blow your [ __ ] outlet
what look at that it's a breathing
technique my [ __ ] the police is working
get the book now Oh boatman the [ __ ]
out night in Washington mr. Biggs give a
shout-out to my main man Bob the voice
aka juicy and Bo Peep down in and if
you're in trouble call my man Gino he's
a police officer
Nupur superb detective and loved with
all my heart
Hoboken representing today and that's it
you know me thought what am i [ __ ] VJ
fresh mango no time to [ __ ] around and
near to you it's [ __ ] Thursday these
[ __ ] gonna be taking my fry
that's when you slip in their [ __ ]
bachelor pool you understand me yes boom
bah she was super hot head
she was soon on a freestyle at door put
it in their mouth floor shooting their
eyeball eat spaghetti and start your
Thursday
I love Utah service you know I'm
a-gettin stone yeah I don't like [ __ ]
fool but there's a [ __ ] this is what
it's all about
get Meghnath has a reef of family you
believe now after all these years it
tempt me we walking in the house are you
[ __ ] nuts or what I'd sent County and
the [ __ ] house Jersey City
oh [ __ ] oh boat and representing Buffalo
is why I love your mother [ __ ] this
Seattle I can't go back there the
warrant they won't drop it they own in
the [ __ ] house whether you nuts or
what
plenty alive no parole it's a [ __ ]
charity day on a [ __ ] morning joint
this thing that so many [ __ ] names
I'm confused
anyway the message of the day is don't
take no [ __ ] from though by the Ohio
Houston the [ __ ] house Tacoma I love
you [ __ ] caught in New Jersey
22 Wilson happen what what wiped 609 my
men might be with the one by one Podcast
are you [ __ ] kidding me
guys have a great day
uncle Joey loves you won't take no [ __ ]
from nobody keep guys off the [ __ ]
phone on the way you get hit in the head
by Isis all right and stay black